the things that make the punisher so
unique and polarizing
go beyond the way he deals with
criminals from the influences that led
to his creation to the strange
evolution on the page here's the
in-depth
untold truth behind the punisher there
are very few comic book characters whose
creation hasn't been influenced by
something else
the punisher was no exception before
frank castle hit the comics page in 1974
there was mack bolan the executioner
created by don pendleton in 1969
the executioner was a series of pulpy
adventure novels that were incredibly
successful
as for what they were about well see if
any of this sounds familiar
mac bolin was a highly decorated green
beret whose service in the vietnam war
earned him an evocative nickname
unfortunately his action as a soldier
couldn't keep him from experiencing
tragedy on the home front
his family was killed in a gruesome
crime that turned out to be tied to the
mafia
prompting bolin to go awol and launch a
one-man war against
organized crime a few years after
pendleton created the executioner
the punisher appeared in 1974's amazing
spider-man number 129.
the version who appears there is a bit
different from how he devolve over the
next decade but you can see the
groundwork in the original story
despite being a hired assassin working
for the supervillain the jackal
he claimed to only kill those who
deserved it and was only targeting
spider-man because he'd been tricked
into believing that spidey was a killer
he also mentions that he's a former
marine but now fights
quote a lonely war originally the
punisher was conceived
as a straight-up villain in the course
of writing the issue
however conway realized that quote he
had a moral code i could use to resolve
story points
as a result the punisher simply walked
away at the end of the story
with spider-man getting out of the whole
attempted murder thing
pretty quickly while he wouldn't get his
own comic for another 10 years after his
initial appearance
it wasn't long before the punisher
started headlining stories of his own
mostly this happened in the pages of
magazines like marvel preview
which were printed without the approval
of the comics code authority
and lent themselves to more violent
adult-oriented tales
all of that changed in january of 1986
and the release of the punisher number
one titled circle of blood
it picked up with frank being sent to
prison at rikers island
which as you may know is a very large
building containing nothing but people
who hate the punisher
it followed frank as he was broken out
by the trust
a clandestine organization that wanted
to fund him in his war against crime
and spark a gang war that would take out
most of manhattan's criminals
the five issue mini-series was a success
in 1987
saw the launch of a punisher series that
would run for over a hundred issues and
cement frank castle
as one of marvel's top characters the
punisher ongoing series was still
definitely a marvel title but the focus
was rarely on super villains
instead much like it had in the
beginning the punisher's
solo adventures drew their influences
from outside comics
that's a nice way of saying that writer
mike baron spent
a few years basically rewriting the
action movie aisle of a blockbuster as
22 page comics
the most egregious example comes pretty
early on
in punisher number 14 frank goes
undercover as a substitute
teacher to root out a drug dealing
operation at a high school
an adventure that bears some striking
similarities to class of 1984
a film that's basically just what if the
guy from death wish was a high school
teacher
to baron's credit though the story where
frank goes undercover with a biker gang
to topple their meth empire actually
predates the release of stone cold
a cinematic flop starring ex-football
player brian bosworth with the exact
same plot
by over a year frank castle kills his
enemies
it's the thing that sets him apart from
the other characters in the marvel
universe
and to a larger extent superheroes as a
whole
there is however a problem with that at
least from a storytelling standpoint
if you kill your enemies they could
never be developed into compelling
nemeses
if you get right down to it that's the
real world reason that batman doesn't
kill the joker he's just too popular to
go away forever
i think you and i are destined to do
this forever
that extends into another problem in
that it limits the scope of frank's
enemies to characters he can
actually kill the punisher's arch enemy
for the first year of his solo title was
the kingpin
and that story never resolves for the
simple reason that it can't
the kingpin is too big a character to be
killed off by a guy who primarily fights
regular human criminals
put those traits together and the end
result is that the punisher by his very
nature
doesn't have many villains who survived
their first appearances
there are a few exceptions to the
punisher's tendency to kill off the bad
guys
and the biggest is jigsaw after
originally appearing in amazing
spider-man number 162
with a shadowy cameo in the previous
issue jigsaw
would return as a bullet in frank's side
for years
jigsaw was built around a pretty simple
concept
in his early days as a vigilante frank
chucked a guy named billy russo head
first through a plate glass window
billy's formerly handsome face was
shredded by the shards of glass
and after it was stitched up into a form
that closely resembled a jigsaw puzzle
he was out for revenge
the thing is none of that really happens
in his first appearance
possibly because it was a little too
violent for 1976
instead when jigsaw first appears all
that stuff is backstory
with the understanding that frank has
been around for a while doing terrible
things to criminals
as for jigsaw there's something of a
recurring gag about how he'll get his
face fixed
only to have it messed up again by the
end of the story the strangest example
of this
might be the time that his face was
healed by a mystically powerful villain
named lucifer
who claimed to be the actual devil
himself that lasted about 15
pages before frank repeatedly rammed
jigsaw's face into a cactus
as the closest thing frank has to a
long-term arch-nemesis in the comics
it's not surprising that jigsaw has made
it into most adaptations of the punisher
including the netflix show this version
of the character had a very different
origin
rather than just being some two-bit
mobster billy russo was an old friend of
frank said he'd served alongside in the
marines
which also made him one of the soldiers
who'd killed an innocent man
who was framed for being a terrorist to
keep a secret
russo tried to kill frank but you
already know how well that works out for
the bad guys
at the end of season 1 frank repeatedly
smashed billy's face
into a mirror considering how violent
the netflix shows can get
it's a bit surprising that billy's scars
aren't quite as grotesque as his comic
book counterparts
instead netflix's jigsaw developed a
fascination with the masks he wore
while recovering from his injuries
decorating them to be creepy
disfigured skulls due to his nightmares
about frank
he did share the original's desire for
revenge though and his success rate
by the end of the 80s the punisher was
well on his way to becoming one of the
most popular characters in marvel's
catalog of heroes
he also had one advantage that
spider-man and the x-men didn't
he didn't have the kind of superpowers
that would require a massive special
effects budget to bring to film
as a result the 1989 punisher movie
in which dolph lundgren starred as frank
castle probably seemed like a safe bet
for low budget success
it was not the film was never
theatrically released in america
and wouldn't hit home video until 1991.
looking back from 30 years later however
the punisher 89 has its share of flaws
but it's also a pretty faithful
adaptation
the plot is lifted from the first year
of punisher solo
comics where frank's war against the mob
has caused them to seek an uneasy
alliance with the yakuza
the origin was changed to make frank a
cop rather than a soldier
distancing him from vietnam but that's
also a tactic that different comic book
versions of the character have used
it's no exaggeration to say that by the
early 90s
the punisher was one of marvel's most
popular characters
if you need proof look no further than
the sheer amount of comics about the
character
that were being published while the
punisher was starring in three titles
every month
characters like captain america iron man
and thor
all had one apiece the avengers had
their regular title and avengers west
coast
the only other characters on or above
frank's level at the time
were spider-man with four and the
all-consuming
unstoppable steamroller that was the
x-men which topped out at
somewhere around nine or ten if you
count everything that had a reasonable
chance of wolverine showing up
on top of that there were dozens of mini
series one shots and specials
all told there were around 26 different
punisher series or one shots published
between 1990 and 1995
clocking in with a total of 343 issues
and three
book length original graphic novels for
comparison
that's how many issues of amazing
spider-man were published from 1963
to 1991. the strangest one by far
however was punisher armory a 10 issue
series written and drawn by elliott r
brown in 1990 punisher armory's first
issue promised to reveal his thoughts
his feelings
his weapons and did exactly that there
was no plot
just full-page drawings of guns and
other assorted weapons
captioned with highly detailed reviews
written from frank castle's point of
view
please note that almost all of these
were real guns
and said reviews often contained frank's
endorsements for real-life gun
manufacturers
the weirdest thing about punisher armory
comes when you try to figure out why it
exists
in the world of the comics themselves if
these are frank's thoughts about his
weapons
then who is he writing them down for why
would you do this only slightly less
bizarre than punisher armory was the
franchise's fourth ongoing series
and the only one that didn't star frank
castle punisher 2099
launched in 1992 the first wave of 2099
books was focused on cyberpunk versions
of spider-man
dr doom and the punisher along with a
new book called
ravage 2099 while the rest of the line
was of varying quality
punisher 2099 is worth your time if you
ever find it in a dollar bin somewhere
jake gallows essentially had the same
origin as frank
family murdered by bad guys big jacket
with a skull on it
etc but when he found the original
punisher's old war journal
he decided to take up his one-man war if
frank was an anti-hero you could
understand
jake was a full-on fascist with a secret
prison
under his house where he kept bad guys
until he executed them by disintegrating
them one cell at a time
he would later become the director of
shield after dr
doom took over the world by 1995
the age of frank holding down three
monthly titles and flooding the market
with spin-offs were over
but to be fair it wasn't just him after
the massive
speculator-driven boom in the early 90s
that had seen comics like
x-men number one selling in the millions
the comics industry nearly collapsed
with a contraction that saw marvel
declaring bankruptcy in 1996.
this led the company to sell off the
movie rights to popular characters like
spider-man and the x-men
leaving them with the ones nobody was
really interested in you know
iron man thor the avengers who would
want to see a movie with those b-listers
anyway after his titles got the axe
frank was caught up in a crossover
called over the edge
which among other things saw him having
a mental breakdown
and killing nick fury fury got better
but frank also believed that he'd killed
an innocent family in central park
much like his own family had been killed
that led him to finally plead guilty for
what we can only assume
were several thousand deaths he was
sentenced to die via electric chair
only finding out seconds before they
threw the switch that the family had
been killed by
bullseye who framed frank so
convincingly that he bought it himself
it will not surprise you to find that
frank's execution was a hoax
instead he was broken out by a crime
lord who wanted the punisher to take
over his empire
punisher joins the mob was an intriguing
hook but the relaunched punisher
only lasted 10 issues in the late 90s
marvel was clawing its way back from
bankruptcy with the time-honored
strategy of throwing whatever they could
against the wall and seeing what stuck
in 1998 however the tide began to turn
that year saw the creation of the marvel
knights in print under
artist and editor joe casada who
hand-picked creative teams with
long-time collaborator jimmy pagliatti
the basic idea was to put the spotlight
on street level marvel characters with a
grittier direction that would hopefully
propel them to stardom
and it worked so well in fact that
casada wound up becoming marvel's editor
in chief
two years later and chief creative
officer in 2010
looking at the four titles that launched
the line it's easy to see why
christopher priest's black panther
redefined the character
introducing lasting concepts like the
dora melange
and blending the panthers cooler than
bond world traveling royal avenger
status with street level action
paul jenkins and jay lee's inhumans was
the most well-regarded run on those
characters since their creation
and has kept that status in the decades
since
the flagship book daredevil paired
qasada with writer and filmmaker kevin
smith
sparking a trend of recruiting from
hollywood that continues
and then there was punisher by
christopher golden tom shinowski
and the legendary bernie wrightson which
is commonly regarded as the low point in
the character's long history
the concept they came up with was very
strange even by punisher standards
after killing himself frank was
resurrected as a ghost and recruited by
angels to hunt down demons
using magic machine guns that he pulled
out of his magic trench coat the twist
was that his
celestial recruitment officer had
actually been his family's guardian
angel
who had been asleep on the job the day
they were killed in central park
unfortunately the book was a flop and a
second attempt at angel punisher the
gastard wolverine didn't improve things
two years after the failed experiment of
angel punisher the marvel knights line
took another shot at frank
this time it worked so well that it
would become the definitive take on the
character
fresh from their massively successful
preacher at dc's vertigo imprint
writer garth ennis and artist steve
dillon took a back to basics approach
of pitting frank against an over-the-top
caricature of the mob
dylan and annis brought punisher the
same blend of ultra violence
grim humor and surprisingly deep
character work that made preacher a hit
it produced what was unquestionably the
best punisher run of all time
up to that point influencing virtually
every interpretation of the character
across
all media for the next two decades annis
would wind up sticking around as the
character's primary writer for the next
eight years with a few scattered stories
since
in that time he oversaw the punisher's
transition from the marvel knights line
to the flagship of marvel max while
marvel knights had been more of a gray
area
the punisher of the max years just did
not co-exist with characters like
spider-man and captain america
propelled by his renewed success in the
comics the punisher would hit the screen
once again in 2004
starring thomas jane as frank castle and
john travolta as the villainous mob boss
howard saint
this time the film was influenced by the
ennis dylan run
bringing in characters like the russian
a nearly indestructible assassin played
by wrestler kevin nash
unfortunately in terms of quality
punisher 2004
is roughly equal to punisher 89 while it
had a little of the flavor of the comics
the movie gilded the lily with some
weird choices that dragged it down
a lot of things that didn't need
explaining were given detailed origins
like getting a skull logo from a t-shirt
as sunbot because it scared him
frank was also an undercover fbi agent
making his family's death a revenge
killing
rather than the random violence of the
original perhaps strangest
the setting was moved from new york to
tampa despite the movie's flaws
jane is a solid choice and clearly
developed a connection to the character
he voiced the punisher in a video game
and pulled out of a sequel because he
didn't believe in the script
in 2012 he even made a well-received 10
minute fan film called dirty laundry
where he reprised the role
even john bernthal who would go on to
play the punisher on netflix was a big
fan
a third punisher film punisher warzone
was released in 2008 from academy award
nominated director and former world
karate champion lexi alexander
starring ray stevenson as frank castle
this time the movie stuck a little more
faithfully to the comics
pitting the punisher against jigsaw and
bringing in microchip
as frank's sidekick unfortunately there
were also some pretty weird choices
notably in giving jigsaw brother a
cannibal named loony bin jim
adding what was essentially just jigsaw
plus to the movie instead of just
focusing on frank's most enduring enemy
the punisher and daredevil have been
linked in comics for years
they're frequently depicted as
ideological opposites
and one of ennis and dylan's most
memorable issues involved frank
explaining his methods by chaining
daredevil up
and forcing him to choose between
shooting frank or letting him kill a
murderer
as a result it wasn't surprising when
netflix's lineup of marvel series
expanded to include the punisher
who first appeared in daredevil's second
season before being spun off into his
own show
despite a fairly positive reception the
show was cancelled
along with all the other netflix marvel
shows in 2019
in advance of the launch of disney plus
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite comic characters are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one